well this week's the castama described
the conservative at leadership race as a
traveling circus he also criticized the
candidates for promising billions of
pounds of unfunded tax cuts laborers
chosen to focus on tax cuts of a
different kind with a pledge to get rid
of the charitable status held by some
private schools and then reinvest that
money in State education well the shadow
education secretary Bridget Phillipson
joins us now thank you for being with us
um I just want to start off by talking
about the Heat Wave and it's something
that so many of our viewers are going to
be really concerned about and the
government is Keen to keep schools open
we spoke to Dominic Rob earlier on the
program who said it's important that
children don't miss school
what's your position on this would you
support schools that do decide to close
in the hoop I think head teachers are
usually the best people to decide what's
right in the particular circumstances of
their school and you know closing
schools should be a last resort of
course it should be I think what we've
seen however over the last 12 years is a
failure to get our schools into the best
possible state to deal with these kinds
of problems that applies when you have
very hot weather but also applies where
you have very cold weather and we've got
a crumbling schools estate and a
government that's failed to invest over
the last 12 years in making sure that
our schools are fit for the future a lot
of parents will be you know facing the
decision about whether to send their
children into school on Monday or
Tuesday particularly Wednesday and when
the heat is so high and would you
support parents who decide to keep their
children off school on those days I'm
sure that head teachers will be doing
everything they possibly can to make
sure that their schools kept as cool as
possible that children are kept out of
the hot sun and are kept indoors as much
as possible I think children have missed
out quite a lot already in terms of
their education and it's right for them
to be there trust their teacher
basically okay they will always act in
the best interests of the children in
school
um I we just spoke to mcwheelan a moment
ago who of course is the head of the
aslav Union at one of a number of unions
that who are going on strike a due back
the train driver strikes we don't want
the strikes to go ahead we didn't last
time and I would certainly want further
strikes to be avoided because whenever
you get to a position where you have a
strike that represents a failure of all
of the parties to reach an agreed
position what we saw with the transport
Secretary of course is that he refused
consistently to get around the table to
try and find a way through it because
this is about you know cost of living
about the rising pressures that workers
are facing and also about safety on our
Railways I mean whether there's any
question now given the chaos that we're
seeing in government about the transport
circuit or whoever that might be in a
couple of weeks doing the right thing
and being responsible in terms of
getting around the table I think that
remains to be seen it's interesting I've
spoken to quite a lot of union leaders
over the last few weeks and it's a
pretty consistent message about Labor
they're frustrated effectively their
labor isn't doing more to support them
in strong action they say that labor
needs to demonstrate that it's a party
that's on the side of working people can
you understand that frustration I
understand the pressures that Working
Families and workers across a range of
different parts of our economy are
feeling right now we know that wages
have been stagnant for many many years
we know that everything is more
expensive and that that means really
hard times for people that do incredibly
important jobs whether that's our
teachers staff on the railways I mean I
think what the trade Unions would
recognize is that from government labor
had a really strong record of making
sure that we did support all of our
staff in those key Industries and that's
what we do again
um you mentioned teachers there who of
course have seen you know pay screens
for many years now with austerity as
well teachers are considering strike
action would you support them in that
well I really hope it doesn't come to
that as I understand it the review body
will be presenting to ministers what the
what their recommendations are I'm not
going to cut across that process but I
think as you say when when you look at
the real terms pay cuts that teachers
have had over the last 12 years the
pressure that they're under the fact
they've worked so hard during the
pandemic and have not been recognized by
the government I think it's also
important however to mention School
support staff who have had you know a
really difficult time are so important
to our children getting the support that
they need in school and of course one of
the leadership candidates was incredibly
dismissive talked about Superfluous
support staff I don't know what plant
she's living on if she thinks we've got
too many stuff in our school supporting
childrenock was very dismissive of our
school support staff but right across
you know Nadeem zahar with a new
Chancellor the former education
secretary he's been saying we've had 20
cuts across government departments I
think that extends to education I think
that he was clarifying the 20 cut was to
civil servants not not the spending on
all government departments well that has
a massive impact I mean who does he
think will be responsible for delivering
on government priorities at the moment
for example I'm inundated with people
who can't get a pass sport to go on
holiday who does he think is responsible
for making sure that people across the
country can get a passport and get can
get a well-deserved break we were
talking about teachers pay and there
were reports that the body that you're
talking about are going to recommend a
five percent pay rise which of course
would end up being another real terms
pay cut if you look at inflation as well
and how much would a labor government
increase Teachers Pay by well let's wait
and see what they say we don't know that
yet I'm not going to put a figure on
that and I'm not going to cut across
that negotiating process the level of
pay and the figure that you put on it is
incredibly important but I know from
speaking to teachers and support staff
as well that there are bigger questions
too around workload and that also needs
addressing I guess I guess I understand
you don't want to cut across blah blah
but at the same time what is the policy
from labor what would be a reasonable
pay rise for teachers well if you look
at our record from government we
delivered consistent stable pay Rises
for teachers and for support I'm not
going to ask about the record I'm asking
about what would be your policy you want
to be the education secretary what what
would be a reasonable pay recipe well I
think you do have to judge us on our
record if I were education secretary I
would be working with trade unions
representing teachers and support staff
to make sure that they are properly
supported both in terms of pay and in
terms of workload that is also why we've
set out that we would end the tax breaks
private schools enjoy we think that's
completely wrong and out of step and
that we would put that money into making
sure that all of our children in our
brilliant State schools get the best
possible start in life okay
um just to quickly End by talking a
little bit about the concept of party
leadership election what content would
you be most worried about fighting in a
general election I'm not worried about
any of them
I don't think we've got anything to fear
from any of the candidates and the
reason for that is that all of them have
propped up Boris Johnson and the
conservative government for 12 years now
and over those 12 years what have we
seen happen in our country we've seen
our Vital Public Services whether that's
schools or hospitals get worse and worse
Britain is completely stuck you can't
renew your passport more and more people
go into food banks Rising levels of
child poverty growth at a terrible level
a consistent failure to grow our economy
and what are they all doing an arms race
around tax cuts none of them prepared to
set out what that means how many
teachers how many doctors what will be
the impact on our Public Services they
should be asked those questions around
what that means and how they will
deliver it labor however we've been
clear that when we put forward any
policy we'll be clear about how we
funded so today we are saying we are
reiterating our call for the government
to end those tax breaks the private
schools enjoy and to put that money into
State education will any of those
candidates make that commitment okay
thank you very much indeed Bridget
Phillips in there for the labor party
here on the show today